[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in this video we're going to be
discussing one of the greatest men
or rather half giants in the harry
potter series
i am of course talking about rubius
hagrid
a hogwarts gamekeeper lover of all
magical creatures
and the man that maybe cared about harry
more than anyone
rubius hagrid was born near 1928 to
father mr hagrid
and a giant tess by the name afrid
walther hagrid gets his immense size
from his mother's side
as hagrid's father was just a regular
sized man
however despite hagrid towering in at a
whopping 11 and a half feet tall
he is considered tiny by giant standards
his mother left him and his father while
he was still quite young
returning to the giant colony from which
she came this left hagrid's father
to raise him alone my dad was
brokenhearted when she went
tiny little bloke my dad was by the time
i was six i could lift him up
and put him on top of the dresser if he
annoyed me used to make him laugh
very little is known about hagrid's
formative years or parents
but his father certainly raised him well
as in spite of his giant size
hagrid was a caring attentive softy who
cared immensely for those that were
close to him
hagrid began attending hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry in the year
and was sorted into gryffindor house
starting just two years
after voldemort himself hagrid was a
promising young wizard
but did have a habit of getting in
trouble trouble which almost always
stemmed
will pertain to magical creatures in
some way
among other things it has been
speculated hagrid did things
like raise werewolf cubs and his bed and
sneak off to the forbidden forest
to wrestle trolls at least that's what
he was accused of
however what would become hagrid's
biggest mistake was acquiring a new
and dangerous pet an acromantula by the
name
of aragog you see in the time that
hagrid attended hogwarts
the school was in a bit of a crazy state
students were mysteriously being
petrified on a consistent basis and no
one knew what was happening
or why it was happening it's later
revealed that the atrocities occurring
at the school
were the result of a young tom riddle
who had opened up the chamber of secrets
and released the fabled basilisk within
when a student was eventually killed
moaning myrtle a witch hunt began to
figure out who exactly was responsible
for the crimes
riddle who was concerned that the school
would be closed then
threw hagrid under the bus and framed
him explaining that the attacks were the
doing of hagrid's acromensula
aragog unfortunately for hagrid he
didn't have much of a chance to defend
himself
this meant that his wand was snapped and
he was expelled from the school
things weren't going well for hagrid
however the silver lining
is that he was trained as game keeper of
hogwarts and allowed to live on the
school grounds
at the request of albus dumbledore the
headmaster of hogwarts at the time
armando dippit strongly believed that
hagrid's pet was responsible
which meant that hagrid's expulsion was
likely not going to be reversed
however given that hagrid's alleged
crimes
responsible for the death of a student
it sort of feels like he got off
easy why wasn't he punished more
severely there are a few reasons for why
hagrid was never held to the full extent
of his crimes
first of all no one believed that hagrid
had any sort of ill intent
though everyone felt that he was guilty
no one believed he did any of it
intentionally which exonerated him to
some extent
secondly dumbledore heavily vouched for
hagrid and knew that he was a kind soul
that needed a second chance despite
dumbledore not yet being headmaster
he still had some sway at the school and
was able to secure the posting of
gameskeeper for hagrid
what was most interesting about hagrid's
expulsion however
was everyone's blind ignorance with
regards to the true culprit
the basilisk living inside the chamber
of secrets
a chamber that existed within the very
walls of hogwarts
the reason that no one ever considered
it as an option was that at that point
the existence of the chamber was either
entirely unknown
or thought to be something that only
existed in fanciful legend
it was the subject of fable a room made
by the maniacal
mughal-hating founder salazar slytherin
but those who knew of it never took it
seriously after book two
the existence of the chamber becomes
more common knowledge
and hagrid is finally properly
exonerated for his crimes
this allows hagrid to become a professor
at which point
he's allowed to perform magic again this
is explained by jk rowling
he is allowed he's been allowed to do
magic openly ever since he became a
teacher
but because he was never fully trained
his magic is never going to be
what it should be he's always going to
be a bit inept
despite his 50-year punishment for a
crime that he didn't commit
hagrid certainly took it all in stride
but he never allowed his unfair
punishment
to make him bitter or angry hagrid is
one of the most wholesome characters
in the entire harry potter universe and
it's just too bad
he was treated so poorly and that's it
for this video
you knew that hagrid was expelled but
did you know all of the ins and outs
how should hagrid be rewarded for 50
years
of false punishment let me know down in
the comments section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
[Music]
you